hahahaha
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to think to die now this
game just came out on gamejolt and I
love games that test the boundaries of
good taste because this game is the only
way to progress is by finding a new and
interesting way to kill yourself and
that sounds horrible and yet here we are
so let's begin this terrifying and
horrible adventure with a new game
really yep that I'm I'm glad you asked
me because I wasn't too sure but now I'm
pretty sure that I want to play this
okay so the concept being it's a puzzle
platformer where this poor schmuck over
here has to go through the world in
wonderful fashion jump and then oh ah
see that's the catch that's the caveat
see I can jump and that's a red herring
but the real objective in all of this
adventure is that it reminds me of this
game made by Jamm tbo to where it was um
you know how he's the guy that made the
little elephant in the cheap I wasn't
ready okay
left click right use mouse keyboard to
move okay ah nice good one but Jamm tbo
too is one of my favorite game
programmers he's me well a while back I
am checked up on new stuff that he's
made but he's really clever programmer
back in the day that made a lot of
really interesting and intricate games
our way one oh falling off the rumor
starts your level okay great I got a
comment from this game is really nicely
designed like ow my face why didn't you
give me evidence a chance to look at the
environment which is awfully nice why is
the background keep bounce bumping oh I
know what to do oh I know exactly what
to do oh I don't know anything what to
do yeah can i double jump yes i gue
wow that's weird okay so I got to move
this over here get down what are you
doing me and sticky on the other thing
ah my face hole so yeah he made a game
called
I try for you at the games Godsey it
achievement unlocked is one of them
yeah how do I know I want to give up how
do I give up
oh okay I understand now it's got Pac
Man esque ability us woo okay but ends
but ends do things and stuff yeah come
on man there's a oh here we go it's a
funky wall jump / double jump situation
that I'm not understanding oh I know
this one this was this was in the
preview and what drew me to this game in
the first place the imaginative ways
with which you can bash your own skull
in whoa
well alright then ah indeed oh yes okay
so hand in the hell am I gonna get up
there Alana's a conundrum
I can't I can't possibly do that mmm
this is a conundrum how am I gonna be
able to get up Oh shitty dicks oh it's
gonna be interesting isn't it oh man I
can't do the weird double jump thing the
wall jump double jump do daddy dangle ah
son of a tits
this is gonna take some brainpower
I'm too stupid how am me do oh oh it's
it's a gosh-darn red herring ain't it
it's a it's a gosh-darn red hair you
don't need noobs you don't you don't
need none of that you don't need that
that's a red herring
coz you can get by with just these and
then all you gots to do I gotta push
these like how about see you didn't need
it it was a red herring I'm a smart
imaginative boy I know what I do so what
do we do now
ah oh oh boom huh me okay that did a
whole lot of dick so maybe if we I know
what we need to do we need to damn it I
ker fumbled it okay so what we need to
do is we need to put this over here put
this over over there push this off yeah
get this over dang it gosh dang get this
over there we go get this over yeah it
did no don't do that
get the door gone it over Dion and boom
am I kind of forgetting that in the end
I'm dying in horrible ways
what is this poor guy's object what is
even this guy's face I can't even tell
what he looks like
okay so that goes over there and what
dur this button do that okay so there's
gots to be way can you think you okay so
there's oh I'm the greatest I found a
way to break the game and win Oh handy
that so this doesn't seem too terribly
complicated I mean the other one was a
lot more complicated than that even
though there's way to exploit it and get
around the mechanics ooh what are you
gonna do to me okay so you got to go
there what do you do
Oh see I see okay so there's no way to
do that quick enough that that's gonna
be able to go the distance so we need to
mmm ain't dis apostle so what do we need
to do in okay that doesn't help nobody
but that might so maybe I could jump
from here
wah almost here well ok what if I hey
hey oh [ __ ] yeah okay
almost here oh damn it yeah there we go
so then drop that well yeah oh hi see it
click the switch button Oh everyone gets
to join in on the party oh so much fun
can we have a multiplayer version of
this but this does add interesting
puzzle dynamics to this so this means
that there's a lot of different ways
that this could go about okay so this
button mood app button does that but we
need that okay so I know what to do okay
so happy oh you left me behind
oh gee horrible game is is like it's
like dawning on me and burst ah it got
trapped in another dimension it's kind
of done in fits and bursts just like the
main concept in this game is pretty dang
horrifying but yeah we did it we're a
winner we get the high score just a
video game
okay so ah okay so we got to get away we
got to get there's got to be a way we
can jump on each other's heads right
yeah
whoop no you get over there get over
there you're a little a little boy here
we go
I should have I should have moved I
should have moved I say the move okay
but I know what I need to do yes yes
yeah get over there you be great
oh boy oh boy oh come on what's up for
you Footwear you forget what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] it
yeah all these controls in okay bad fig
yeah
Oh give me some figgy pudding [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] it cocking aah oh man
sometimes when I'm pushing right it goes
left that's what they call bad control
what the [ __ ] was that it bounced up the
other guy yeah all right okay let's try
this again with a little less suck hey
no see uh watch what the problem is I'm
pressing the jump button up it don't go
up I have to go out and then up and then
maybe that works sometimes so it's not
now there we go whoa ah gotcha okay
nailed it allows you to jump higher is
it a springy spring pool boy here's a
spring East brewing yeah why why are you
not jumping why are you not jumping
higher god damn it are you kidding me
stop jiggling
just let me jump let me jump Oh
you sack of [ __ ] let me we're really
gonna be like that huh do I get a bounce
multe oh you the other guy went fine but
no Mimi I'm bad here we go okay I might
do a few more levels and then we're
gonna get to the end of this one here I
made it well house Oh hard Oh hard no oh
okay this way tell it I got it I'm gonna
do a few more and then we're gonna get
to the end of this video but it's an
interesting imaginative concept not a
great concept all I mean I mean it's an
interesting concept but I mean like
from a moral standpoint of what's
happening here pretty horrible but alas
it's a Vinci game I know we need I know
we need hit hold that for me
I put this over here we nah
there we go okay that's the last level
that I'm gonna try here so I like this
game there's an imaginative twist to it
and a really dark sinister twist to it
that you know is is really dark and
sinister and that's all I have to say
about that but I've heard there's
actually a hundred and thirty-five
levels in this game it's a name your own
price type game too and it goes without
saying this is not reality this is a
game it doesn't reflect anything in
reality so don't take any of these
themes seriously so I hope you enjoyed
this video please try out this game it's
down in the description below and thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
this time we're gonna get it I guess
this is a metaphor for a threesome bloop
bloop not for the kitties